Are you going to shoot me maybe well
probably but not right now action
when we start secret Invasion Nick Fury
has been off planet and Maria Hill has
just really been trying to you know maintain
order but this current threat is getting out
of control five Global terrorists strikes
within the past year each one playing by
a different group it's business as usual
that's precisely what they want you to think
and it comes back having lost whatever
power he had before so we try and solve
things without being too superhuman you're
going to shoot me maybe well probably not
right now we get to jump into Nick Fury's
World which is very spy versus despite the
kind of grittiness the locations the way it
feels the way it's written it's a thriller
Fury we gonna be very careful now I
had to pinch myself many mornings when
I would step on set with Olivia Coleman
Sam Jackson Don Cheadle Emilia Clark Ben
benedir I mean some of my favorite actors in
the world alone at last after every Marvel film
released I would phone my agent say please
can I be in a Marvel thing I never imagined
it would happen what makes you think you can
get him to speak oh I can be quite persuasive
looking at the MCU to these different lenses
you get to see all these different sides of
the characters so we get to really sort
of dig into who they are how much do you
know about your security detail what do you
mean how much do I know about it this idea of
who can you trust that is really the heart of
the show they could be talking to somebody who
have a very close relationship with and then you
find out that that's not who you thought it was
it becomes sort of a cat and mouse game that
we we build toward to the end of the show
you can't predict it and you can't preempt it
and you can't fathom it until it happens
I'm Nick Fury even when I'm out I'm in
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie. Marvel just
dropped a brand new secret Invasion trailer so
we'll break it down there's a whole bunch of new
footage if you're brand new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get the videos of course
I'll be doing episode videos for this one at
premieres next month one of the really interesting
things that's going on during this series is the
introduction of more British Marvel characters
kit harington's Black Knight is a really good
example of that there's a connection between the
Union Jack character who we'll see during this and
people like Captain Britain who I know people have
been asking for in the MCU for a long time so I'll
explain how they're all connected there's a whole
bunch of new footage of Emilia Clarke's character
she's basically like space Khaleesi they're
setting her up as a big character in the future
of the MCU I believe she'll be working with Nick
Fury on his saber space station after the events
of this series she's not playing Abigail brand but
in the way that Marvel changes a lot of comic book
backstories I think they're giving her a lot of
Abigail Brand Story in the future basically that
role and I love the fact that Samuel L Jackson
is wearing a Samuel L Jackson t-shirt he's like
one of the few people who could get away with
that without people calling him pretentious
this version of secret invasion is meant to be
based more on the political paranoia infiltration
aspect where Nick Fury is trying to find out who
all the skrulls are and we know a couple of the
big characters in the MCU are going to secretly
be skrulls it won't be quite the same thing as the
comics like every single Avenger isn't going to be
in this like we won't see a version of Spider-Man
who is a skrull in this but there are big rumors
that we'll find out that some big characters like
the US president possibly even Rhody wind up
being skrulls the whole idea is that they're
using this to pave the way for Marvel's dark Reign
which they kind of did in the comics too like dark
rain came right after secret invasion in the wake
of what happened during secret Invasion so it's
kind of the same Vibe with this version of MCU
secret Invasion it's not quite as connected to
the larger Kang Multiverse plot either the whole
dark reign of Marvel Phase 5 with villains coming
to power like they did in the comics is kind of
like a separate thing but just starting at the
beginning of the footage working our way through
shot by shot talking about Easter eggs as we go
along so at the beginning of this you see Nick
Fury running through the streets in the middle
of the night trying to find another skrull he's
basically chasing them down through a lot of
the series trying to find out where they are who
they're pretending to be with the help of Talos
and his daughter played by Emilia Clarke who is
playing a character called Gia she was in the
original Captain Marvel movie they're just saying
that she's that little girl and she's grown up
since then but the whole idea is that she has deep
connections to this evil group of skrulls and the
whole idea is that the evil group of skrulls is
sort of a faction within talos's larger faction
of skrulls that are tired of waiting around for
Nick Fury to find them a new home they become more
militant and to decide to take the Earth as their
new home like fine we'll just take it from them
we're tired of waiting and as Samuel L Jackson
says at the beginning of the trailer here Nick
Fury is operating at a fraction of his power he
doesn't have all the resources that he had before
and the reason why they say that he spent so much
time away from Earth on the saber space station
with Talos pretending to be him sort of filling in
for him and duties like we saw during Spider-Man
far from home is because he was so broken after
the events of Avengers Infinity war and Avengers
end game so normally coming into Marvel movies
he's in this position of power like he's this
very fearsome person but coming into this he's in
a vastly weakened State Kobe smolders is back as
Maria Hill the real version of Maria Hill not
Taylor's wife she said that she's been running
around the planet while Nick Fury has been gone
since Avengers end game trying to keep everything
together you remember that she got snapped along
with Nick Fury so she was gone for that five-year
time Jump too but the way she yells at Nick Fury
a little bit in the previous trailer she's kind
of mad at him because she's been trying to contact
him to inform him about what's happening with the
skrulls and he hasn't been answering her but now
he's finally come to planet Earth to deal with it
we get a look at Everett Ross who's talking to
this other character here I'm not sure who this
character is supposed to be it just seems like
someone who's clued into what the skrulls are
doing maybe he's part of one of the intelligence
agencies and he's gone full Charlie Day meme board
in the background behind him with all these
conspiracy theories about what the skrulls are
doing but he's actually right because the skrull
is all trying to take over you remember that
because of the events of black panther wakanda
forever Val had him arrested for trying to help
the wakandans and then Okoye broke him out so
essentially he's been a fugitive ever since
then not that much time has gone by but a little
bit of time has gone by so so he's also trying
to help Nick Fury but from the shadows as well
and it sounds like the skrulls are orchestrating
these terrorist attacks around the world to try
and destabilize the world governments to create
this environment of fear that will cause them to
attack each other weaken their states and will
enable them to take over much more easily they're
using all their secret identities pretending to be
people to sow Discord on planet Earth they kind of
teased that during black panther wakanda forever
the whole idea that a lot of the world wanted
wakanda's resources the whole idea that everybody
all these different nations around the world post
Snap aren't getting along that well I believe
that'll also culminate too during Captain America
and the Thunderbolts movie with tiamit the whole
idea that the celestial is full of all kinds of
cosmic resources I think they're even saying that
adamantium in the MCU comes from Team its body
and it winds up turning into this race between all
the different world Nations like Val Thunderbolt
Ross who's the U.S president to try and claim it
all for themselves before other nations take it we
get a much longer scene of Olivia Coleman's Sonia
ballsworth character interrogating who I think
she believes is another skrull is even though
she's poking in torturing him just a little bit
trying to get him to change Sonya fallsworth is
meant to be the daughter of the original Union
Jack who was part of the Halle Commandos Captain
America's Howling Commandos during World War II
if you haven't read any of the Union jack-related
Comics he doesn't have any special powers he's
just super highly trained he doesn't even have
super soldier serum but their family is also a
little bit like the Black Knights family where
the mantle gets passed down from father to son to
daughter to whoever to like the Next Generation
so his descendants wind up taking the title
but Union Jack relatively small character in
the comics usually when people think about British
characters they think about Captain Britain maybe
we'll see a version of Captain Britain show up at
some point in the future a lot of Marvel's British
characters the British Comics rose up through
the King Arthur mythology so a lot of the Black
Knights history Captain Britain those characters
is tied up with the King Arthur Chronicles
mythology there are a couple references to Camelot
during the eternals movie King Arthur Excalibur so
we know that those characters do exist in the m
to you but we'll see if they ever wind up paying
that off I think the next place that we'll see
kit Harrington's Black Knight character now it
used to be the blade movie but I believe the next
place is coming back now is going to be eternals
too but they didn't say when that's going to be
released it could be years before that comes out
Olivia Coleman said that her Union Jack character
is a little bit more like a British version of Val
a little more Sinister bend the same way you see
that smile on her face like she's being all cute
with this skrull she's getting ready to torture
him the same way that you see Val act all sweet
but she's really really a terrible person we
get a little bit more from Don cheadle's Roadie
and Emilia Clarke's GIA one of the big things
they've revealed about Roadie is at this point
in the timeline he's been the right hand man like
the Secretary of State to the U.S president for a
good long while and there's even a rumor that
he's going to wind up being a skrull too like
he is one of the characters who is secretly
a skrull the whole idea is that Thunderbolt
Ross has to become the US president by the events
of Captain America four so in order for that to
happen you either have to kill off the current
U.S president or he has to be a skrull himself
so you can Theory craft all you want if roady's
gonna be the skrull then maybe he's the person
that gets rid of the president or if somehow the
US president is discredited because members within
his cabinet like the other people that work around
him wind up being skrulls he winds up being voted
out of office in favor of Thunderbolt Ross who's
going to be a way more hardcore version of a U.S
president part of the idea with dark rain is that
the villains take power I think they're giving him
some of the Norman Osborne storyline where after
secret Invasion Norman Osborne came to power he
took control of Shield I think for Thunderbolt
Ross that's the U.S presidency but like even
before this during black panther will Connor
forever or by those events Val has become the
director of the CIA she already wields enormous
power and is doing all kinds of shady stuff with
it I believe she's going to be the person who will
also be behind the new weapons plus program or the
new version of it they talked about that during
the original Incredible Hulk movie Thunderbolt
Ross had started that again the Hawaii with the
weapons plus program is that it's like the super
soldier program continuation where they continue
to try and make super soldiers using different
means so like Captain America is weapon one by
the time you get to Wolverine Weapon X is actually
Roman numeral he's weapon 10. he's just like the
next iteration of the weapons plus program even
Deadpool is part of the weapons K program which
is kind of like an offshoot of that but you can
see during their clip here where Nick Fury is
trying to explain to Rody about what the skrulls
are doing infiltrating all these important groups
all these World governments like how much do you
know about your security detail some of them might
be a skrulls but also Roadie himself might be a
skrull let me know in the comments though which
characters do you want to wind up being skrulls
like is roadie really going to be a skrull there's
also rumors about Sharon Carter actually secretly
having been a skrull for a while now too and I
just did a video about the super skrulls like
the extra powers that some of these skrulls will
have during the secret Invasion series like the
whole idea is that some of them the new generation
evolve more Powers kind of like the super skrull
there's a couple other big videos that I'm working
on a bunch of stuff happening the next couple of
weeks bunch of big movies coming out too so be
sure to enable orders for my channel so you don't
miss that and that special Guardians of the Galaxy
and Star Wars giveaways are still going so I'll
announce winners for those in the next couple
of videos Everyone click here for that secret
Invasion super skrull video and click it from my
new Daredevil Born Again First Look video with the
Punisher thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!